hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my flash episode 17 video just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet there was so much comic-book
stuff going on I'm the dude who's
playing a dude pretended to be another
dude now you understand why he was
probably so quick to sign on to the role
when they asked him to be on this TV
show hold the phone you're gonna get to
play like four different characters in
the span of the next two years because
there were so many comic book Easter
eggs I'm just gonna do my top ten like I
would normally do you know hit the
Easter eggs as I Rick roll along so
let's go starting with number 10 Kaelyn
tells Barry in no uncertain terms that
his running technique is not as good as
the reverse flash or zooms they don't
really address it but I loved how she
took the time to make that animation she
could have just told Barry that
information like oh your legs are moving
at the same speed but your feet spend
less time on the ground but no she took
the time to make that After Effects
project so that she could visualize it
number 9 WTF not necessarily comic book
Easter Egg but very important point
iris explains to Barry that she went on
a date with her boss and his reaction is
kind of like all of our reaction like
wait a minute
you went on a date with your boss isn't
that kind of problematic that's kind of
a headache waiting to happen especially
in real life if a female journalist were
to do that she would be heavily
criticized that people found out that
she was dating her boss you could just
hear all the angry bros in the
background just screaming at her that is
why it's just better to not date people
you work with
but number 8 Barry travels back in time
to learn from the reverse-flash how to
get faster without velocity-9 sees a
time Wraith and it throws him off he
ends up traveling to a time that's too
early the wraith i think is the show's
version of doing the black flash the
problem with doing the black flash is
that they already have a speedster
wearing a black costume so i think
that's why they're calling this a wraith
the way they explain it also kind of
lines up with the definition of a wraith
the black flash appears and is kind of
like a herald for the death of the
speedster a wraith is an apparition
that's known to appear heralding your
own death it becomes a little clearer at
the end of the episode when the wraith
gets a hold of barry and starts to drain
his lifeforce and he starts to look like
the wraith they'll probably explain this
in a future episode like they'll come
back to the idea of time rates but this
is just them
leading the idea in so I think it'll be
a bigger thing in a future episode but
already off to a bad start number seven
WTF berry vs. berry from the past you
can see that even though Berry's been
getting faster his ability to fight
hasn't been getting that much better he
learned how to phase he can travel
through time but that doesn't really
make him a better fighter and he's not
really trying to hurt himself either he
doesn't want to kill himself or anything
like that and eventually number six WTF
already things going a little off the
rails he changes the future by warning
them about Hartley's bomb inside his ear
there were a lot of people that were
criticizing the Supergirl episode this
week the crossover episode for riding
Barry as being not a good fighter but
you could also say in this episode that
he immediately starts by doing the very
first thing that they told him not to do
change the past why you asked do writers
write him that way like why do they make
him derp so much well that's just
because there wouldn't be a story if he
didn't make mistakes it's the same thing
with arrow and Oliver Queen so when
you're looking at the flash and you're
like oh how come he's messing up so much
it's because he hasn't become like the
badass comic book flash yet that's a
much older version of the flash number 5
WTF
eobard thawne from the past totally
figures it out right away
wait there's a time wraiths there's only
one reason time wraiths would be here
because Barry says it's been following
him he just immediately connects the
dots
I love the reveal too he just stands up
just clocks them in the back of the head
that first conversation they have where
Wells reveals himself like oh you're not
you're not surprised that I'm standing
up that I'm moving super fast you know
who I am it's a little confusing Barry
does successfully lied to him at the
promise of the message of how to defeat
him and win the future that's how he
blackmails Wells into helping him into
not killing him but I like the way it
changes the performance of Wells later
like the way he acts around team flash
where he's like you shut up you shut up
you shut up I think what you're trying
to say is that you are from the future
number 4 WTF Barry from the past wakes
up comes back and they do their version
of who's on first the only other way to
fix the situation like this would be for
Barry from the future to time-travel
again to even further in the past and
then stop the earlier version of himself
from doing anything in the episode like
the minute he gets back he's just like
dude seriously
don't even try this go straight back to
where you came from that would be the
only other way to erase the damage that
he'd already done but they don't do that
in number three WTF this is probably one
of my favorite Easter eggs we are not
the only two speedsters there are many
members in the flash family we've seen a
lot of them already on the TV show in
one form or another
like Jesse quick Wally West if you
broaden the definition of speedsters
they're almost like thirty speedsters in
the comics you get the idea there are a
ton of them out there this is the show's
way of just teasing you that yeah we're
probably going to see some more
speedsters number two WTF Cisco Rick
rolls the [ __ ] out of Pied Piper
probably one of my favorite non
comic-book Easter eggs as the flash TV
shows ever done and because of the
things that Barry derps in the past
they've changed the future
but now Pied Piper has repaired his
relationship with his parents and he's
kind of good so this is the show just
trying to be a little more hopeful with
its Terminator storylines typically when
you tell a story like this usually the
future gets changed in a bad way and
finally my number one WTF the reverse
flash gives Barry the information on how
to build a tachyon device tachyon
enhancement is what he calls it that was
what he was trying to do during season
one when he was trying to soak up more
Speed Force he was trying to use that
tachyon device that he modified as you
will notice from the supergirl crossover
episode he's wearing one of those when
he bursts through dimensions so I'm
guessing at the end of next week's
episode they're gonna explain how he got
to supergirls earth if you guys saw my
Supergirl crossover video I explained
that because their production schedules
were all out of whack they had already
shot all these flash episodes before
they shot the Supergirl crossover so
that's why they didn't have a scene
explaining how he got to supergirls
earth one more though this is kind of a
bonus moment but Harrison wells from
earth-2
during the future when he comes back at
the end of the episode mentions his dead
wife for the first time and they haven't
revealed who she is she's just a quick
smother I think they're saving that for
something special in my mind she's gonna
be earth to Tina McGee but she could be
anybody and they did say that the next
episode of the flash even though it's on
break next week is gonna be zoom
backstory so it's actually gonna be
pretty cool and now the Barry can jump
through dimensions that's probably how
he's going to get back to earth too but
let me know in the
what was your favorite part of this
episode was it Rick rollin
was it the reverse-flash saying that
there are many other speedsters that can
time travel this is one of those
episodes where they had extra fun like
you even had Rick cause that they got
Rick cosmetic um back and guest stars
ready to shoot new footage so all the
Eddie stuff was brand new I really like
how they're able to play with their own
continuity of the show like you go back
and you watch season 1 and it plays out
a certain way you watch this season 2
episode and it completely changes their
timeline that makes me wonder what they
could do in season 3 but I don't think
that they're gonna use this story device
again very soon they'll keep using time
travel in stories but not in the same
way that they did in this episode where
they retcon themselves in a major way
but it is kind of funny to think about
holy Harry Potter Rick rolling great
episode so there's a bunch of TV that
I'm super behind on I haven't done a
Gotham video I haven't done agents of
shield so I'll try to at least do
something for Facebook I still have some
daredevil so be sure to subscribe to get
all that there's a new episode of arrow
this week in new legends of tomorrow if
I don't have time to do a Jonah Hex
video before legends of tomorrow I'll
just talk about him whenever I do my
next Legends video and giveaway time
congratulations to this week's Batman V
Superman ticket giveaway
Jaden Washington please private message
me on the back end of my channel so I
can get your contact details that's just
on the about page in case you guys
haven't seen it I just posted a big
Captain America trailer video you can
click here to watch that and you can
click here for my Justice League deleted
scene from Batman vs Superman thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
type up I'll see you guys tonight